foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Thursday February 2nd I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
Microsoft is taking steps to position
itself at the Forefront of artificial
intelligence development it's investing
billions into open AI the startup behind
the viral chat bot chat GPT accompanied
first invested in back in 2019 but AI
that can generate text and images is
still novel and imperfect technology so
what can Microsoft get out of this
partnership and how are big competitors
in the AI space reacting
joining me to discuss this is our
Microsoft reporter Tom Dutton hi Tom
welcome to the show thanks for having me
so we know Microsoft is investing
billions in open AI what else do we know
about this partnership Microsoft is
really leaning in pretty heavily into
this partnership as both a way to
bolster its image and also to enhance a
lot of the products that it sells so on
the one standpoint just from a purely
product standpoint they are going to be
incorporating this in their CEO Satya
Nadella has talked about everything from
search it's being search engine
to its products like it's office suite
to any other kind of consumer facing
thing they believe that open Ai and its
technology can make a lot better and
more compelling to Consumers and then
just from an image standpoint they've
tapped into this very of the moment tech
company that is so popular in the tech
world and it's at the Forefront of this
whole Revolution or hyped revolution of
generative AI that people really believe
are going to transform almost every
technology that we can think of these
days I'm sure a number of listeners have
tried out chat GPT if you have it's
pretty easy to use it can be pretty fun
but there are some limitations to the
tech can you tell us what those are and
what it means for Microsoft the biggest
limitation to the tech is that it isn't
always accurate so it very confidently
produces a response to almost any
question you put its way whether or not
that response is factual based on
verified sources is just not there yet
there's been quite a lot of criticism
even from the CEO of openai that chatgpt
and the various iterations of this
so-called large language model
technology doesn't always produce
accurate results it's baked into the
architecture of how these things are
made and uh if you're talking about say
a search engine which theoretically
should be directing people toward
accurate information you would want when
you're asking a question something to
give you the correct factual response if
it's not going to give you that if it's
going to make something up or kind of
head Edge facts or in just some ways
muddy the line of what a real human
derived Source would send you it's a
huge problem if it's going to be a
replacement for search
Microsoft had all commented on
the most that I have seen from Sacha
Nadella is in an interview at Davos a
couple of weeks back
he was asked about this problem of it's
called hallucinations when the
technology just fabricates a response
claiming it's accurate but actually it's
not based on any real Source material
and his response to that was basically
like
yeah we recognize this as an issue we
view it as a solvable one it's an
engineering problem and Engineers exist
to solve engineering problems so he
really downplayed the idea that this is
something fundamental and flawed within
you know generative AI or large language
models
he tries to answer a question like
a person has run across the Atlantic
Ocean something like that actually let's
do this while we're do you mind do you
want to find out what it says this could
be interesting no tell me what chat GPT
has to say about the fastest time to run
across the Atlantic Ocean all right
let's see oh they're at capacity right
now this is a real problem they have I
mean there was a case a couple of weeks
back where people were asking it who the
CEO of Twitter was and it was saying it
was Elon Musk which in and of itself was
funny because chat GPT is not designed
to know anything after 2021 Elon didn't
become the CEO until last year so that
was already kind of fishy but then it
was starting to claim all this stuff
that Elon stepped down as CEO or that he
was killed in a car accident I mean just
completely made up stuff and the CEO of
openai has said this is an imperfect
technology it has a habit of doing it
and the question is is this solvable is
this something that the next generation
of GPT or whoever else is building this
Tech will be able to solve or it's just
like you always have to have some sort
of caveat in any response you get from
it that listen this just may not be
right and you should do your own
research to make sure before you move
forward with that answer
well here now I'm on a I was able to get
into chat GPT so let's see if it can
answer a question thinking
thinking
this is of course another issue with
chatgpt which is that it can just take a
really long time to turn out a response
and so
I'm sure trying to be a replacement to
Google which is a pretty much like
automatic thing you really gotta not
have these problems oh here we go no
human has ever run across the Atlantic
Ocean as it is a vast ocean
and it is not possible and then it said
network error so I guess the problems
exist Beyond just being factual
such a big invest ment I wonder who's
concerned about this who feels like they
might be falling behind because of
Microsoft's investment in open AI the
most obvious one in this case would be
Google there's been a lot of discussion
publicly and internally at Google over
whether they've kind of missed the boat
on this generative AI Revolution and the
reason that it's so kind of flagrant
with Google is because they have done
more than almost any company to advance
this technology they acquire this
company called deepmind which was really
at the Forefront of large language
models and generative AI they've been
working behind the scenes to build out
this technology as Google likes to say
to people the T in GPT which stands for
Transformers that whole technology was
invented by deepmind and furthered by
Google so in a world where chat GPT or
gbt three or four or whatever other
version of this technology poses some
sort of a real threat to search then yes
Google is arguably in a rough spot
because they have not been as aggressive
as open AI has been in terms of
releasing this technology widely to the
public all right that's our Microsoft
reporter Tom Dotan thanks for joining us
Tom thanks for having me
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories check out
our website wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal thanks for
listening
thank you
[Music]